but I make three editions of each neon
sign so that I can share them with more
people in the world and actually put
them more places in the world later that
same year I made a second edition that
ended up being acquired by the
smithsonian's Renwick gallery and around
that same time I started having
conversations with Xander as he said
about where in the world we could bring
this sign that would be a meaningful
place to the organization it was around
that time that I learned about this
property on Mount Washington in Nevada
and the fact that it's the home to some
of the world's longest living trees the
Bristlecone Pines some of which have
lived over 5 000 years that process of
actually imagining what we were about to
do and then making it a reality took
about a year and it involved making a
third edition of the neon sign with my
studio assistant Jess Greene in my
studio in Dallas Texas and I made this
sign specifically for this opportunity
the the scale of it and also the way
that it's constructed in modular
components so that it can easily
assemble and disassemble so here you can
see it in the back of a moving truck and
the sign structure is made of steel
right and all of the glass components
are stored in that wood crate
and I just want to take a second to
acknowledge the fact that we use glass
for this specific project because it's
kind of insane
and the most insane part about it is
that I didn't make any backups
so we only had one piece of glass for
each part of the sign and if any of them
broke along the way we would have been
screwed but we probably would have found
ways of making it still happen but that
materiality of glass was actually a
really important part of this project
for me because I think it really speaks
to that fragility of like possibility
reality relationships right and it's
interesting to think about when the
culmination of an idea draws nearer and
we could we've been planning for a year
and we can now really imagine what it's
going to look like on this Mountaintop
but the closer we got to actually making
that a reality the more fragile all that
sense of possibility actually became
because one broken letter could have
like totally made it potentially
impossible
and one of the most significant
challenges as you can see here was
getting the glass up this mountain
safely up to 11 000 feet it's so
interesting to learn about the
Bristlecone Pines and the fact that they
actually thrive in these really extreme
conditions that you can only find at
these you know really high elevations so
it was really interesting to try to make
that Journey up to this place where they
live and of course we had to do all
these crazy switchbacks and the road was
dirt and there was all these huge ruts
and every time we went over a bump I was
freaking out inside
but thankfully I was in really good
hands and I also had like a whole team
of people who were so equipped and like
fully you know acquainted with
installing art projects in really
extreme environments so we arrived at
the Mountaintop around noon and after
lunch we immediately got to work
assembling the signs struck picture and
our goal was to have everything set up
by Sunset and this video for me really
shows how fast that afternoon seemed to
go by and I think it's kind of funny
because it might be the shortest term
project the long now Foundation has ever
done
as you can see we did manage to get the
sign up and working right before the
sunset and I'm so thankful we did
another artist and also along now
research fellow Jonathan Keats something
that he said about this particular
moment was how it allowed us to witness
the simultaneity of so many different
time scales right the flashing on and
off of those words every three seconds
coupled with the passing of the clouds
overhead Gathering and parting and then
the change of the light as the sun set
over the course of about an hour all of
those things were then juxtaposed with
the lifespans the 5 000 year old trees
that were surrounding us right so it was
quite a magical experience
but one thing actually that did not go
according to plan
um was that the electronic flasher that
I typically use to change the states of
those signs that every three seconds
actually didn't work and we couldn't
figure out why we thought it had
something to do with the electricity
coming out of the generator not jiving
with it we couldn't figure it out so
ultimately I had to plug and unplug
these different sections of the neon
sign at this power strip and you can see
in this video how determined I was to
keep that Rhythm really consistent for
me it's so so so important that each
state of the sign lasts three seconds
not four not two three seconds right and
that it repeats over and over and over
again creating that really sort of
meditative experience so when you look
at this video I'm imagine me off to the
right hand side of the scene counting
One Mississippi two Mississippi three
Mississippi
that sort of meditative and very
Mechanical Rhythm of the sign became
kind of like a ticking clock you know
and that was juxtaposed with our own
lived experiences of time and the length
of our own human lifespans so people
really love to photograph the sign when
it's illuminated of course right but
that third state where all the words
turn off for three seconds is actually
really important for me because from my
point of view it actually returns our
attention to the landscape and this was
especially crucial here in this really
epic landscape right the base in the
range Province I actually learned is
home to some of the highest mountain
peaks in the contiguous United States
and that elevated perspective is also an
important conceptual component of this
project because I like to think that
shift in perspective that bird's eye
view that we get from a Mountaintop as
being really similar to that broader
perspective of time right seeing that
longer now yet another time scale we can
experience when we look out at that
landscape is the geological time scale
and the time it takes for geological
forces to stretch the Earth's crusts and
to form a mountain as the sun set the
Stars began to appear and I don't know
why but for some reason this was very
unexpected you know when you think about
putting any inside on the mountain you
think about like the sunset but I never
could have imagined that the Milky Way
the band of the Milky Way would
literally be right behind it it was
beautiful and this revealed a whole
other time scale that of galaxies and I
didn't actually know until the other day
that our Galaxy is spinning did you know
that
and then it takes about 240 million
years to complete one rotation so here
in this one image we have two vastly
different time scales right A present
moment that lasts depending on how you
think of it three seconds or nine
seconds and one that lasts 240 million
years
so what I've always loved about this
quote is the way that we can each relate
to it like on a very individual level
and when we think about this present
moment and how it was once unimaginable
we can think about our current
relationships or the kind of current
state of our career but I also love how
it can also kind of speak to a more
Universal level and things that are
going on in the world that you know
affect all of us I like to think about
how if this present moment was once
unimaginable how it naturally makes you
wonder and want to try to imagine you
know what the future will hold so I
personally I'm trying to imagine a
future of gender equality of equal pay
right and equal access to abortions
wouldn't that be something but
but I wonder what you are all imagining
for the future I think in moments like
this which we had sort of gazing out at
the world from a Mountaintop or you
could have gazing up at the stars at
night or that feeling you get when
you're standing in front of a work of
art that like really really moves you
that broader perspective that you get
that bird's eye view or that feeling of
awe maybe can give you a new way of
understanding the world right it can
give you that shift in perspective and
it can help you see the bigger here and
the longer now
and the roles that we play in it both
individually and also collectively
and I think that that shift in
perspective can actually help us imagine
otherwise unimaginable Futures and this
was definitely an unimaginable future
for me at some point being able to stand
beside Stuart brand and gaze up at this
sign that I made Illuminating his words
I'm really grateful for this experience
I'm also really grateful to all of these
people who participated in this project
some of whom are not even pictured here
but thank you all for helping make this
moment a reality